Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Henry Cavill Superman
Man of Steel 2 video we found out what's
going on with the next Superman solo
movie it has a lot to do with what's
happening with the next big Superman
appearances including the Justice League
Snyder cut so we'll break it all down
there's a bunch of Easter eggs if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos will do a new
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and let me know
what you want them to do for the story
of the next Superman movie so starting
with number five if you have no idea
what's going on recently The Wrap
reported on the status of Henry cavils
new Superman contract that he's signing
it Warner Brothers and what's going on
with Man of Steel 2 or if you just want
to call it a neck stand alone Superman
movie we don't know what it would be
titled either way it's still Henry
Cavill which means technically any new
Superman movie that he appears and by
default would be connected to the first
Man of Steel movie in Justice League
even though there's been talk of reboots
and everything going on because of
what's happening with the Batman the
same is still true for other new DC
movies with the same Justice League
actors everything is still connected to
Justice League for the most part the
only big recasting recently was Robert
Pattinson as the Batman but that's a
special case because Ben Affleck is also
coming back as Batman for the Justice
League Snyder cut says the suit is bad
news building
so that's what you did funny right I
mean we have to lunch at somewhere but
the other big news about Henry Cavill
Superman was that right now his new
contract he's working out is just like
Mark Ruffalo's Holt contracted Marvel
for all the Avengers movies and the
other crossovers that he's been in he
crosses over into other movies but
there's no Hulk solo movie planned right
now in Marvel phase 4 the big difference
between Henry Cavill and Mark Ruffalo's
contracts though is that Mark Ruffalo
signed a standard six picture deal
originally when he first appeared as the
Hulk in the Avengers movie henry cavill
'he's new contract is reportedly only
for three movies so number four the
movies that they're reporting he would
appear in would either be Shazam to the
Black Adam movie with the rock the flash
flashpoint movie or Aquaman 2 but it
would be multiple appearances some of
them would be bigger than others like
pink thor ragnarok with the hulk being a
pretty big part of that storyline it'd
be a version of Superman doing that in
other upcoming DC movies but some of his
appearances in those other movies would
be bigger than others some of them would
just be little cameos some of them will
be much bigger he already had a cameo at
the end of the first Shazam movie so
he's technically already crossed over
with that franchise in Shazam and Black
Adam movies are still connected to the
Justice League and DC EU the whole
reason he showed up in that scene is
because Shazam met the Justice League
and asked Superman to do him a solid for
the Shazam Lee the director even posted
a funny meme video of him photoshopping
Henry Cavill face on there because it
was so much hype about the Justice
League Snyder cut in then revisiting old
movies adding new footage in the real
reason why you didn't see Henry Cavill
face there at the end is just because of
a scheduling conflict with mustache
impossible fallout Tom Cruise broke his
legs so they had to delay filming on
that movie to coincide with the filming
dates for the Shazam movie it also
caused problems for the Justice League
movie too everybody heard about that so he
just didn't work out but it is supposed
to be Henry Cavill Superman after the
events of the Justice League movie in
the Justice League Snyder cut alternate
storyline for Superman isn't  going to
affect any of that continuity he still
winds up in relatively the same place
for the most part a year after the
Justice League film
everyone knows the rock has been trying
to get Henry Cavill Superman in his
Black Adam movie for years while it's
been in development he even commissioned
boss logic to create this fan art of his
black
Adam fighting Superman a couple years
ago in Jason Momoa is trying to get
everyone to cross over into his Aquaman
2 movie including Wonder Woman but as
cool is Superman crossing over with all
these characters is going to be everyone
just wants to know what's going on with
the next Superman movie so number three
get this the new report from The Wrap is
saying that the reason why Warner
Brothers hasn't formally announced Man
of Steel 2 yet is mostly because of
their new deal with JJ Abrams in his bad
robot company if you didn't see that
news earlier this year
AT&T paid about a half a billion dollars
to JJ Abrams to bring all of his
business to Warner Brothers that means
all of the new TV shows and movies he
develops will be Warner Brothers movies
including some of the new DC movies and
TV shows they just announced his first
big DC project is going to be a super
big-budget HBO Justice League dark
series here's the thing though
Superman in the Green Lantern Corps
movie were also part of the JJ Abrams
announcement it was reported that Warner
Brothers wants him to be involved in
revitalizing the entire DC brand with
their biggest IP Batman is kind of an
exception to that because Matt Reeves
has that all locked out right now so JJ
Abrams isn't going to be doing any kind
of Batman stuff but if Warner Brothers
is touting JJ Abrams doing a new
Superman project why is he doing Justice
League dark first well the main reasons
they're reporting are apparently because
Warner Brothers doesn't think a Henry
Cavill Superman movie like Man of Steel
2 is a box-office sure thing right now
into JJ Abrams apparently wants to cast
his own Superman so 2, because of all the
Justice League Snyder cut hype right now
Warner Brothers is just  going to let that
play out through next year letting Henry
Cavill cross over into other short term
upcoming DC movies to keep him in the
general public consciousness so that
people just remember that there is a
Superman out there they're  going to wait to
see how everything performs before they
commit another 200 million dollars to a
Superman movie with Henry Cavill like if
the Justice League Snyder cut does well
I know everyone's wondering will they
continue that DC EU Universe that line
of story in other upcoming DC projects
is possible that they could do something
like that but technically as long as the
same actors are playing those characters
it still exists but because this new
Henry Cavill Superman contract is going
to take him to the
next three years or so worth of movies
hopefully by that time JJ Abrams will
make up his mind about whether or not he
wants to keep Henry Cavill as his
Superman in a new movie or if he in the
studio decided to pull a full Batman and
just recast with a new actor rebooting
the character so right now the best
thing you could do if you want to see
Henry Cavill do Man of Steel 2 in a
couple years it just supports the
upcoming DC movies that he is going to
appear in the first new one being the
Justice League Snyder cut next summer
and it sounds like if everything goes
well in another couple years JJ Abrams
will probably be asked to do justice
league 2 most likely patty Jenkins was
also asked a while ago if she would do
justice league 2 and she was very
hesitant even James Gunn recently was
asked about doing Avengers 5 and he said
no way I'm not  going to do an Avengers
movie he had no interest in it
whatsoever just because there were so
many characters and it's so hard to do
big movies like that really well the
list of directors that can handle big
team-up movies like that is very very
short
and even if the Justice League Snyder
cut does really well I don't think that
Warner Brothers would bring Zack Snyder
back to do another Justice League film I
think best case scenario they would let
him work on other upcoming HBO max
projects but number one as for the
actual plot of Man of Steel 2 everyone
is hoping JJ Abrams doesn't try to do a
version of his Superman flyby script if
you don't remember that project it was a
total reimagining of the Superman mythos
they created an original character based
on Zod to be the villain with a
completely different name completely
different backstory and it was  going to
happen back in the early 2000s the
script for that is actually online you
can read it if you want although I would
not recommend it they've been all kinds
of jokes from Hollywood writers pitching
their ideas for bankable Superman movie
ideas but all you really need for a good
new Superman movie is something fresh
new villains that they've never done in
the live-action movies before like
Brainiac as a solid example without
being too different from what's come
before because remember it would still
be in continuity with the previous
Justice League DC EU films in the first
Man of Steel film best example of this
is actually Wonder Woman 1984 believe it
or not it's not a reboot of the Wonder
Woman franchise but Zack Snyder had a
big role in the creative in the story of
the first Wonder Woman movie that's why
he's listed as an exec
producer in the credits Wonder Woman
1984 is the first Wonder Woman movie
that is fully just patty Jenkins
creative top-to-bottom beginning to end
which is why it looks and feels very
different totally so it's kind of a
creative soft reboot without being an
actual reboot they're not retconning
anything from the first Wonder Woman
movie so if another director winds up
doing Man of Steel too with Henry Cavill
Superman or whatever they want to call
the next movie man of tomorrow that's
kind of what would happen soft creative
refresh of the character without
retconning anything from the first Man
of Steel movie and in fact if you guys
didn't see there is an actual Superman
man of tomorrow animated DC movie that
they just did it's coming out later this
year but there's no official release
date for it yet if you didn't watch it
Justice League dark apocalypse war is
the last big DC animated movie as part
of that line of continuity it's
fantastic a lot of the plot of that is
similar to Zack Snyder's original plot
for the Justice League trilogy when they
were still  going to do a trilogy of Justice
League films so this Superman man of
tomorrow movie is one of the first new
sort of rebooted DC animated movies let
me know in the comments though what do
you want them to do for the story of the
next Superman movie and when they do
make some more announcements about
what's going on next with Henry Cavill
Superman I'll do a new video but
congratulations to mal Alfred you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everyone click here for my brand-new
Wonder Woman 1984 trailer video in
Justice League Easter eggs and click
here for my brand-new Doctor Strange 2
teaser Easter eggs video thank you so
much for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!